dr weiss bonsoir
la troisième dose entendait pas plus
tard que la semaine dernière
un spécialiste dire mais pourtant la
deuxième dose l'efficacité semble tenir
pas mal est ce qu'on doit se précipiter
pas nécessairement pourquoi on
recommande aujourd'hui cette troisième
dose à tous les adultes
d'abord il faut revenir en arrière à peu
près tous les pays du monde ont déjà
recommandé cette troisième cause là donc
on sait que les états unis l'europe
israël qui a vu les données déjà depuis
l'été dernier sur l'importance de cette
troisième dose les provinces canadiennes
ont embarqué très rapidement déjà
l'alberta la colombie-britannique
l'ontario ont déjà des plans surtout
pour vacciner les plus de 50 ans et
vacciner les travailleurs de la santé
c'est prioritaire ça fait déjà des
semaines qu'on dit hier que le québec
actuellement qui n'a pas encore pris de
décision réel les rapides à cet égard là
pourquoi ils troisième dose parce qu'on
sait qu'après six mois l'immunité semble
un peu diminué et que même s'il ya une
certaine protection qui demeure même si
on a une certaine protection au paradis
c'est vers on commence à avoir ce qu'on
appelle des briques fraction des
infections s'ils voulaient qu'il passe
au travail due au travers des mailles du
filet chez les travailleurs de la santé
principalement même s'ils sont pas très
malade mais aussi des travailleurs de la
santé qui vont finir par créer des
infections nosocomiales en infectant et
personnes qui sont hospitalisées des
gens dans les ch et celle des terrains
potentiellement parce que ces gens là
perdent leur immunité avec le temps
maintenant d'avoir trois doses pour un
vaccin pour un virus c'est pas anormal à
vous savez l'hépatite b le virus du vph
on donne souvent trois doses pour avoir
unitaire plus long terme et les données
commence à être assez clair pour montrer
que la troisième dose à cet effet si
vous voulez de 2 m si vous voulez cette
espèce de 2 d'augmentation de l'immunité
et de protection à plus long terme alors
dans le contexte où les chiffrer le
nombre de cas augmente au québec même si
on sait que c'est beaucoup chez des
jeunes même si on sait qu'il ya pas
tellement plus d'hospitalisation mais
que ça augmente tranquillement et dans
le contexte de la période des fêtes etc
terrain on veut pas se retrouver au mois
de janvier avec un nombre plus de cas
avec des travailleurs de la santé malade
même s'ils ne sont pas très malade mais
suffisamment malade pour pas venir
travailler et on veut surtout pas que
les patients les plus à risques ce soit
les patients marie l'est par exemple
avec des immuno des patios nino
compromis que ces gens-là tombale a donc
cessé on est arrivé là avec la troisième
dose et là vous parlez des employés de
la santé vous parler des gens veut les
ramener dans votre esprit dr weiss est
ce que tout le monde même quelqu'un qui
est très en santé qui à
50,45 même devrait selon vous y allez
quand ça sera offert
oui écoutez c'est un peu dans le sens
des trois doses alors évidemment ce
qu'on sait pas et dans le futur une
c'est comme ça on aura les données les
trois doses à tout le monde est ce qu'un
pré saint jouan n'aura plus besoin de
vacciner par exemple les moins de 60 ans
en pleine santé on va leur dire cela
vous avez vos trois dont vous allez bon
pour cinq ans est ce qu'on va devoir
vacciner peut-être les plus de 80 ans
une fois aux deux ans sans ne sait pas
encore mais me les trois doses vous
savez quand à la naissance les et on les
vaccine souvent avec des vaccins à deux
mois 4 mois 6 mois donc l'aspect de
donner des doses en série de trois comme
ça c'est pas nouveau pour le système
immunitaire donc éventuellement à plus
long terme si on va avoir une efficacité
de protection de longue haleine c'est ce
que la troisième d'autres semblent faire
et c'est ce que la la littérature semble
démontrer actuellement alors je pense
que l'idée c'est d'essayer de protéger
le plus de gens possible pour rémy
longtemps possible il ya des questions
encore qu'on ne connaît pas sur la durée
de la protection l'aspect survie variant
etc mais je pense que globalement on est
rendu là c'est ce qu'il fait dans tous
les autres pays on n'a rien apporté et
rien dit d'extraordinaire et justement
j'allais vous rentrez le varia nadal le
nouveau variant migrants en fait dr nous
à ottawa dit aujourd'hui c'est même pas
en fonction du nouveau variant qu'on
recommande ça il n'y aurait que le delta
on le recommandera également
oui tout à fait parce que d'abord au
canada pour l'instant le delta c'est de
loin le plus prévalents et donc
l'expérience des autres pays qui ont
vacciné plutôt que nous et avec des dos
je vous dirai plus se rapprocher on peut
discuter de la l'espace idéal entre deux
roses on sait aujourd'hui que c'est
quelque part entre six et huit semaines
mais on sait que même pour le delta
salle en effet positive maintenant pour
le variant au micron même si les données
sont très préliminaires et c'est très
très je dirais limiter ce qu'on a tant
donné il semble que le variant au micron
les gens qui sont doublement vaccinés
sont protégés contre une maladie sévère
c'est à dire que même s'il tente le
positif ils sont très peu malade ils ne
sont pas développer une maladie sévère
c'est très préliminaire on n'a pas
encore toutes les données mais disons
que c'est déjà encourageant bon on a on
a souvent utilisés ensemble des
analogies guerrière je vous montrais
deux graphiques nos défenses semblent
tenir quand même bon le nombre de cas on
va le voir en deux semaines on a fait
une corde sur deux semaines le nombre de
cas oui augmente au québec on va le voir
dans une seconde voilà le nombre de cas
quotidiens oui augmente 1355 aujourd'hui
on était il n'ya pas si longtemps 517
mais le nombre
d'hospitalisations montiel coach
allemand mais légèrement saas et les
hospitalisations voient leur quotidien
la ligne en bleu c'est une bonne
nouvelle ça c'est une très bonne
nouvelle et ça c'est la combinaison de
plusieurs facteurs c'est la combinaison
de la campagne de vaccination qui a été
fait au québec qui montrent l'effet
protecteur sur une grande majorité de la
population surtout les plus vulnérables
et les plus âgés et son le montrer que
c'est d'autant plus remarquable qu on a
ouvert la société c'est à dire que là on
fait beaucoup plus de choses les gens
sont retournés à l'école on voit au
cinéma ou au restaurant va où jim on
fait du sport on va au centre bell donc
en dépit de l'ouverture de la société
dans un certain point en a quand même un
nombre de cas qui est oui qui a augmenté
mais un nombre d'hospitalisations qui
lui n'a pas tellement augmenté et qui
reste quand même gérable ce qu'on veut
pas c'est que ce nombre va augmenter
savait que la période des fêtes peut
être un multiplicateur un peu comme la
grippe le virus dako vite c'est un virus
respiratoires qui est bien l'hiver donc
on veut pas se retrouver au mois de
janvier avec une augmentation importante
des hospitalisations surtout des
personnes à risque qui va encore bloquer
le système mais
il faut savoir que c'est un ensemble de
mesures qui mises ensemble sont cons on
arrive à tenir la route de façon assez
adéquate c'est à dire y'a rien à rien
d'absolu la vaccination c'est pas 100%
efficace le masque c'est pas 100%
efficace donc la distanciation ça roule
un petit peu à jouer mais c'est quand on
ajoute tout ça ensemble et qu'on met
toutes les barrières ensemble qu'on
arrive si vous voulez à maintenir une
situation satisfaisante à l'échelle
sociétal pour qu'on puisse de
fonctionner de façon normale parce qu'il
ya personne qui veut revenir un
confinement il ya personne qui veut être
isolé et serra et c'est la façon de
garder la société ouverte en terminant
dr weiss on ne pourra pas faire
l'économie d'une vaccination
internationale les chiffres en afrique
les chiffres en inde les chefs en
amérique du sud sont très bons en ait si
je pensais 2% le taux de vaccination
nous rappelle ces 80 2%
à peu près au canada 84 au québec
est ce que vous imaginez un scénario où
ces pays là ne serait jamais vacciné
non je pense que dans un premier temps
il faut savoir que la production de
vaccins à l'échelle planétaire va être
capable d'être suffisant pour vacciner
tout le monde deuxièmement il ya quand
même des efforts déjà qu'ils sont faits
de certains pays pour permettre aux pays
plus pauvres d'avoir accès à ces vaccins
là il y a dans certains cas je vous
dirais des problèmes d'accès logistique
dans certains endroits il ya aussi des
fois des vous dirait des saveurs refus à
être vaccinés dans certains endroits
comme comme en occident comment dans
certains pays d'asie également donc il
ya un ensemble de facteurs je ne pense
pas que c'est un aspect limitatif vous
savez il ya des handi dès fois les pays
pauvres mais il ya des ondes riche dans
les congrès et vous avez et vous avez
des fois des zones riches dans les pays
pauvres qui sont beaucoup mieux vacciner
que les zones pauvres des pays riches
alors il faut aussi remettre les choses
en perspective
mais c'est très important qu'on essaie
de vacciner tout le monde sur la planète
le plus possible tout en sachant que ce
virus la rva porte probablement et il
est d'ailleurs en train de passer d'une
pandémie
démis c'est à dire qu'il va falloir
vivre avec vivre avec avec je vous
dirais un certain bruit de fond mais
dont on va s'accommoder dans l'impact va
être limité parce que d'abord il ya des
réservoirs à niveau vous voyez que ya
des des cervidés qui sont atteints il ya
des sénat qui sont atteints même s'ils
sont pas très malade mais ça veut dire
que même si on va signer toute la
planète 100% de la planète et qu'on
protège et tout le monde est le vaccin
ne peut jamais être 100% protecteur il
va toujours rester des coronavirus covic
19 quelque part sur la planète
hippique qui pourrait revenir dans
l'espèce humaine et à un moment donné
donc ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que il faut qu'on ait un vaccin qui nous
protègent contre la maladie sévère donc
finalement si on se retrouvait avec un
petit rhume de temps en temps c'est pas
très grave et qui protège le système
hospitalier contre un tsunami de 40 ans
devra hospitalisés et qui nous permettra
de retourner à une vie normale et
finalement je dirais avec une
perspective historique ça ressemble
peut-être à ce qu'on a appelé la finança
russe de 1889 qui était peut-être un
coronavirus qui s'appelle aujourd'hui
non ces 43 qui est devenue la cause d'un
simple rhume avec les années et les
décennies et donc c'est peut-être
l'évolution de ce virus d'ailleurs on
voit que quand on n'ira pas avec le lot
micro montrent que c'est peut-être moins
sévère donc on sait pas comment ça va
évoluer on peut faire des scénarios mais
on est là passer de pandémie à endémie
dr weiss merci beaucoup bonne fin de
semaine merci pour lui mais également au
revoir pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit